rencontre aujourd'hui entre vladimir
poutine et rachael tayyip erdogan les
présidents russe et turc eux vont se
retrouver en milieu de journée à sotchi
sur les rives de la mer noire au menu
des discussions notamment l'afghanistan
ou encore la syrie mais aussi le
partenariat russo turque ankara a
d'ailleurs confirmé sa volonté d'acheter
un deuxième lot de missiles russes les
précisions de notre correspond à moscou
entre une cléroux la rencontre en face à
face entre le président russe et son
homologue turc est déjà un événement en
soi en effet cela fait deux semaines que
vladimir poutine ne voyait personne car
étant à l'isolément en cause des cas de
kovy 19 dans son entourage les deux
hommes se rencontrent donc à sotchi sur
les bords de la mer noire pour évoquer
de nombreux sujets d'actualité tels que
l'afghanistan la libye le haut karabakh
ou encore la syrie justement la
situation en syrie en particulier dans
la région d'idleb qui a connu une
recrudescence des combats ces dernières
semaines et bien est en tête de liste
des préoccupations des sujets de
discussions qui vont être abordés
d'après le porte parole du kremlin il
sera également bien entendu question des
relations bilatérales entre la russie et
la turquie lors de ce tête à tête
d'ailleurs en amont de cette rencontre
le chef d'état turc a en quelque sorte
fait un pied de nez à washington en
effet lors d'une lors d'une interview
télévisée à une chaîne américaine à la
chaîne américaine cbs il a rappelé sa
volonté de conserver les systèmes de
défense anti missiles russes s 400 et
pourquoi pas d'en acquérir de nouveaux